add and simplify the answer and write as
a mixed number so we have two mixed
numbers here and have a whole number
part and a fraction part we need to add
them now there's two ways to do this you
could convert both of these into
improper fractions then add them and
then convert that back into a mixed
number or you could just look at this
and say well you know what 17 + 2 9 17 +
2 ninths is the exact same thing as 17
plus 2/9 and then 5 and 1/9 5 and 1/9 is
the exact same thing as 5 plus 1/9 so 17
+ 2 9 plus 5 and 1/9 is the same thing
as 17 plus 2/9 plus 5 plus 1/9 these two
statements are completely equivalent and
we know that when you're just adding a
bunch of numbers it doesn't matter what
order you do it in so you can swap the
order so you could say that this is the
same thing as 17 + 5 17 plus 5 plus 2/9
plus 2/9 plus 1/9 plus 1/9 and we could
do this in any order and we know what 17
plus 5 is we've done that before 17 plus
5 is 22 so that part right there is 22
so we have 22 + now what is what is 2/9
plus 1/9 well they have the same
denominator so it's going to be over 9
so it's going to be over 9 and then you
add the numerators 2 plus 1 is 3 so it's
22 + 3/9 but this can be simplified both
the numerator and the denominator are
divisible by 3 divide the numerator by 3
you get 1 divide the denominator by 3
you get 3 so this is 22 plus 1/3 which
is the exact same thing which is the
exact same thing as 20 to 22 and 20 let
me write in that other blue color which
is the exact same thing as 22 and 1/3